hello this video is about some exciting
joint work with an india day in rarcoll
video
and it's about quantitative correlation
inequalities
so let me start off by telling you what
a correlation inequality is
you've got some probability space and
you're interested in some class of
functions of this probability space
and a correlation inequality simply
tells you that any two functions
belonging to this family are not
negatively correlated
these are very fundamental very useful
tools in combinatorics and statistical
physics if you were to grab your copy of
loan and spencer for example you'd find
then
find an entire chapter devoted to these
sorts of statements
perhaps the simplest correlation
inequality is the hardest kleckman
inequality
it says that any two monotone boolean
functions on the n-dimensional hypercube
are not negatively correlated
so the n-dimensional hypercube is just a
collection of zero one strings of length
n and a function is said to be monotone
if flipping an input bit from zero to
one
cannot cause the value of the function
to decrease
and this inequality is not too hard to
prove in fact we'll essentially prove it
in a few minutes
it's also been known for over 50 years
it was proved in 1966
a more recent correlation inequality is
rhoyan's inequality which was proved in
2014
it concerns symmetric convex sets of a
gaussian space
whereby gaussian space i just mean rn
end out with the standard gaussian
distribution
and we see i said is symmetric if it's
symmetric about the origin in other
words if a point x is in the set
then the point minus x obtained by
flipping the sign of each of x's
coordinates is also in the set
and roy's inequality says that if you've
got two symmetric convex sets
then the indicator functions of these
sets are going to be non-negatively
correlated with respect to the standard
gaussian distribution
another way of stating rhoyen's
inequalities that follows
as follows it says that the gaussian
measure of
the intersection of two symmetric convex
sets is at least the product of the
gaussian measures of the sets themselves
there's many other correlation
inequalities for different interesting
classes of functions and a bunch of
different domains
but in this video we'll just be focusing
on the two examples we just saw the
harris titan inequality and roy's
inequality
one thing to note about both these
statements in fact
all the inequalities in the previous
slide is that they're all qualitative in
nature
all they say is that this correlation
between any two functions belonging to
some family
is non-negative and so it's natural to
hope for a better lower bound on this
correlation
um perhaps in terms of some property of
the functions that we are considering
and with this in mind let's actually
revisit the harris kleitmann number and
try to
try to see what a quantitative version
of it would look like
so here's how is kleitman you've got
these these two monitor and boolean
functions
on the n-dimensional hypercube and an
actual thing to do
is to define restrictions of these
functions to the n minus one dimensional
hypercube as follows
so given the function f you can define
this new function f
zero obtained from f by fixing the last
bit of f to be zero
and you can similarly define g zero by
fixing the last bit of g to be 0
and you can define f1 and g1 by fixing
the last bits of f and g to b1
respectively
now that you've got these restricted
functions you can express this
correlation between f and g
in terms of these restricted functions
to obtain this expression
this is not too hard to see and feel
free to pause the video and verify this
but each of the expressions on the right
hand side is a is a pretty interesting
quantity
in particular the first one is is
nothing but half the correlation
between the restricted functions f zero
and g zero
the second one is nothing but half the
correlation between the restricted
functions f1 and g1
and so if you were trying to prove
harris klitman by inducting on
the dimension of the hypercube n then
since these functions these restricted
functions are n minus one dimensional
they're going to be non-negative by the
inductive hypothesis
and this third quantity it's an
interesting looking quantity which some
of you might have seen before
let's actually just focus on the first
term in this product
and and feel free to take a moment to
verify this
um if the function f is monotone then
this highlighted quantity is precisely
the probability
that when you choose a point x uniformly
at random from
the the boolean hypercube the value of f
at that point
differs from the value of f at the point
obtained by flipping the last
bit of the original point x
and this is a well studied notion so let
me see a little bit about this this
quantity
um in slightly more generality so given
a boolean function on the n-dimensional
hypercube
you can define the influence of any of
its n coordinates
as this probability of um
of this probability that when you choose
a point uniformly at random from the
hypercube
the value of f at that point differs
from the value of f at the point
obtained by flipping
the coordinate you're you're interested
in
and this this this probability is the
influence of that coordinate
it captures in in some sense how much
the function f depends
on that particular coordinate and
there's been a long line of very
interesting
um very exciting work built around this
notion of influence
returning to harris kleitmann it's easy
to see
that the hurst knightman inequality is
tight or in other words
this correlation between two monitoring
boolean functions is zero
if and only if for each coordinate
the influence of that coordinate on
either f or on g
is zero or in other words at least one
of f or g
is independent of that coordinate
and so it's natural to hope for a better
lower bound in the harris kleckman
inequality in terms of the sum
of the products of the influences of the
two functions
and what this what this quantity is is
capturing is in some sense
how much the functions f and g depend
simultaneously
on the same set of coordinates and such
a lower bound was obtained by telegram
in 1996.
telegram showed that if you've got two
monotone boolean functions on the
n-dimensional hypercube
then you can lower bound the correlation
between these two functions
in terms of this function psi of the sum
of the products of the
influences of the two functions
and this function psi of x is defined to
be x over
log of e over x and this logarithmic
factor turns out to be necessary so
telegram's inequality is tight
tolerance proof is not not so easy
and the the the key technical lemma is
this decouple level two inequality for
those who are familiar with boolean
function analysis
and this this this key technical lemma
has many interesting applications
elsewhere in common directs and boolean
function analysis
so to summarize the situation so far
we've got these two really nice
qualitative statements for
monotone boolean functions over the the
n-dimensional hypercube
and for symmetric convex sets of
gaussian space and telegram comes along
and robustifies the expression on the
left
to to obtain this really interesting
looking correlation inequality
and it's natural to hope for a robust
version of ryan's inequality or
a telegram analog for symmetric convex
sets of a gaussian space
that's precisely what we obtain in this
work we show that
the correlation between any two
symmetric convex sets
can be lower bounded by this function
fee of the sum of the
influences of these convex sets so this
this inequality looks a lot like
telegram's inequality but
uh a key difference is this function fee
which has an additional
logarithmic factor in the denominator
and i also haven't told you what the
this notion of influence for symmetric
context that or gaussian space is
so let me put up our results in slightly
larger font um
this is the main theorem that we'll be
after for the rest of this video
and along the way i will actually tell
you what this new notion of influences
for symmetric convex sets actually is
and i just want to emphasize one thing
that
i will say more about later but the
strategy we use to prove this theorem
generalizes very easily to a bunch of
different domains
in particular if you're if you want to
recover telegram's result of a
0 1 to the n you can essentially
follow the strategy we'll be using to
prove this theorem
and obtain the quantitative correlation
inequality which looks like telegram's
inequality but has this
additional logarithmic factor or in
other words has this fee function as
opposed to telegram c
function let me sketch the proof
strategy we'll be following very very
briefly
so you've got these two symmetric convex
sets knl and we're interested in the
correlation between these two sets
and what we're going to do is we're
going to be interpolating between each
of the two terms and this correlation
quantity
and there's a natural way of doing this
by starting with the expectation of k
times l
and adding noise to the inputs of one of
these two indicator functions say to k
and eventually you add enough noise that
this noisy version of k becomes
independent
of l and so this expectation splits into
the expectation of k times the
expectation of l
and we'll be doing this interpolation
using the unsteadily black noise
operator
once we've got this interpolation we're
going to be expressing it as a power
series
and we'll be doing this using the hermit
basis and we'll require a complex
analytic lemma
which i won't be proving in this video
but essentially the lama says that
that the the value of this power series
is going to be large
at some point along the interpolation
and finally because of the monotonicity
of this interpolation
we'll be able to conclude that the the
correlation between these two sets is
large
this monotonicity turns out to be a
consequence of avoidance proof of the
gaussian correlation inequality itself
and so the rest of this video will look
like this we're going to start off by
doing some harmonic analysis of a
gaussian space i'll define this hermite
basis and the the noise operator
after which we'll briefly touch upon
ryan's proof and then we'll put all
these ingredients together to get the
quantitative gaussian correlation
inequality that i i showed you a few
slides ago
and finally you'll see a little bit
about this new notion of influences for
symmetric convex set
and i'll tell you how the strategy
generalizes to the domains
so let's get started um we're going to
be interested
in the vector space of square integrable
functions of a gaussian space
uh l2 as in and we're going to be
thinking of it as an inner product space
where the inner product between two
functions f and g is simply the
expectation of f times g
and it's a standard fact that the
hermite polynomials
the univariate hermet polynomials form a
complete orthonormal basis
for square integrable functions of a
one-dimensional causing space
the exact expressions for these
polynomials um
don't really matter all that really
matters for us is that they're
orthonormal
so we've got this nice orthonormal basis
for functions of a one-dimensional cars
in space
and the natural thing to do is to
tensorize them to obtain a basis
for functions of n-dimensional gas in
space
and so a little bit of notation given an
n-tuple
um of natural numbers alpha we're going
to define this
multivariate hermet polynomial a sub
alpha
where a sub alpha of x is defined to be
the product of the
of of the univariated hermet polynomials
a sub alpha i
of x i it's a standard fact that
the collection of these multivariate
hermet polynomials is a complete
orthonormal basis for square integral
functions
of n dimensional gaussian space in other
words this lets you write
a function in l2
as a combination of these multivariate
hermet polynomials
and this this this combination is this
expression is called the hermite
expansion of this function f
in particular these f tilde alphas which
are real numbers these coefficients are
called the hermite coefficients
and the collection of these coefficients
is the hermit spectrum
an easy consequence of orthonormality of
the hermetic basis
is that given to functions f and g with
these hermet expansions
the inner product of f and g which we
defined to be the expectation of
f times g is nothing but the sum of the
products of the
corresponding hermite coefficients of f
and g
this is pretty much all the harmonic
analysis we'll need um
so let's actually move on and to move on
to the noise operator
so there's the the unseen little black
noise operator is analogous to the
bonami because operator over the boolean
hypercube
and it's defined as follows given a
function f
you can you define the new function u
rho of f
as as follows you know f of x is defined
to be the expectation
of f of rho x plus square root 1 minus
rho squared g where the expectation is
taken with respect to g
this this number rho ranges between zero
and one
and we're going to be thinking of it as
a as a noise rate
where when rho is large we are adding
very little
noise to the function and when rho is
small you've added
lots of noise to this new function you
row f
and essentially if this function is a
cons forgets about the input
more concretely when row is set to one
it's easy to see that
you've row f of x is just f of x and
when rho 0 0 f of x is just the constant
function
which is the expectation of f so as
you're decreasing
rho from 1 to 0 you're adding more noise
to the function
and this unstable and black noise
operator um interacts really
really nicely with the hermit basis and
before i show you
how it does how does that um we need
some notation
given an n tuple of natural numbers
alpha we're going to be
defining the degree or the level of
alpha and also
by base of notation the degree or level
of a fourier coefficient f delta alpha
as the sum of the entries of alpha and
we'll be denoting it by this absolute
value of alpha
and it's a it's a really awesome fact
that the the hermit basis is
diagonalized by
the instantaneous operator in other
words if you've got
a function f with the same expansion
the hermit expansion of euro f looks a
lot like the hermite expansion of f
but with all the hermit coefficients
scaled by rho
to the degree of the hermit coefficient
and so just a quick summary um of of
this
section given a function f in l2 you can
write it's a meat expansion
um you've got parseval's formula which
is an easy consequence of orthonormality
of the hemi basis
and you've got this really nice noise
operator which
interacts really nicely with the meat
basis
and a good reference for all of this is
chapter chapter 11 of ryan o'donnell's
analysis of boolean functions
so let's move on to ryan's proof um in
case you've forgotten
where our drawing showed is that any two
symmetric convex sets
um are non-negatively correlated under
the gaussian distribution
and what we're going to do is we're
going to be expressing each of these
these terms in this correlation the
expectation of k times l and the
expectation of k
times the expectation of l in terms of
an inner product of
a noisy version of k and l a different
noise rate
more concretely um it's easy to see that
the expectation of k times l is nothing
but the inner product of
u row k and l when rho is set to one
and the expectation of k times the
expectation of l is the inner product
between zero k and
l when rho is set to zero in other words
the noise is very high
and so roy's inequality says that this
inner product
at noise rate one is greater than the
inner product at noise
noise rate 0. so let's actually see how
ryan
proves this um so here's ryan and
here's what he wants to prove he wants
to show that this inner product at 0
is going to be less than or equal to the
value of the inner product at one
and ryan ryan's inside was to look at
not just these two and
these two points of this the value of
this inner product of these two points
but
actually at the value of this inner
product at
all noise rates between these two uh
noise rates
so you end up with a curve that might
look something like this
um and ryan doesn't seem too pleased
with this curve
because it it's sort of sort of a wild
curve it goes up and then down and then
all the way back up again
and drawing realizes that this actually
cannot happen
um ryan ryan comes with drawing
run shows um that the curves gotta
look something like this more formally
what ryan shows is that this inner
product between
euro k and l is increasing in this noise
noise parameter rho
so once you've got this this
monotonicity of this inner
product um this
this quantitative this qualitative
causing correlational equality
is immediate it's an easy consequence
and this monotonicity will be crucial
for us as well when we prove
the uh when we prove the telegram
analogue for symmetric conducts that's
okay in space
so let's move on to proving this this
gaussian
robust gaussian correlation inequality
so we
we have these two symmetric convex sets
and we want a quantitative lower bound
on the correlation between them
which we have an expression for in terms
of the difference of this inner product
at two different noise rates
since we defined the hermite basis um
let's actually write down these two this
this uh inner product in terms of the
hamit um
coefficients of their functions k and l
so the hermite expansion of euro k
is given by this expression and the hemi
expansion of l is given by some
expression
on the right and because of parseval's
formula
it follows that this inner product is
the sum
of the products of the hamid
coefficients the corresponding hamid
coefficients of knl
multiplied by rho to the
power uh rho raised to the the degree of
the
the hermit coefficients and so
um let's subtract the
inner product at noise rate 0 to obtain
this expression
which is the sum of the products of the
hermite coefficient scaled by rho to the
degree of the hamid coefficient
where the sum is taken over hermite
coefficients of
degrees strictly greater than zero
just to re-parameterize this expression
um we can write it in terms of a power
series as follows
um this is a power series in rho
uh whose coefficients ai ais are
given by um the expression on the slide
and in particular ai is defined to be
the
product of the hamid coefficients of k
and l of degree i
um and
it's easy easy to see using the koshi
shorts inequality and parseval's
inequality that the sum of the absolute
values of these coefficients
is at most one and
because k and l are symmetric um the
indicator functions of k and l are even
functions
and it follows that
the hermit coefficients of k and l of
odd degree are going to be zero
and this is because um the multivariate
hermet polynomial a sub alpha
is even if the degree of alpha is even
and it's odd if
um the degree of alpha is odd
so let's incorporate these two facts
into this this
power series um the symmetry will
kill off all the the indices a sub i
when i is odd so you can just write this
in terms of these even indices
um and we have this additional
constraint that the sum of the absolute
values of these coefficients is at most
one
and we're gonna actually pull out this
a2
and write this difference as a2 times
this new power series p of t
and there's some nice properties about
this power series p of t
its constant term is zero in other words
p of zero is zero
um the lead the linear coefficient
is one and the sum of the absolute
values of the coefficients is bounded by
one over a two
this is a consequence of the fact that
some of the absolute values of the
of the ais is bounded by one
and this new variable t is nothing but
rho squared so we've just
re-parameterized this to make
things slightly easier for us and the
question we're interested in
now is how large the largest value of p
of t
is as t ranges over the unit interval
once you've got this once you've got a
lower bound on the supremum
it's easy to get a low bound on the
correlation because of ryan's proof so
this was a bit of a spoiler and it'll
become clear in a few a few moments
so we've got this power series and we
want to lower boundaries to premium of
this power series and
it actually turns out to be easier to
analyze this question in
slightly more generality in particular
instead of restricting
um the coefficients of these power
series to be real numbers
uh we're going to be thinking of complex
power series
so you've got some power series p of t
um
with complex coefficients such that
the the constant term
um is zero in other words p of zero is
zero and
the coefficient of the the linear term
is one
and you're interested in the modulus of
p of t as t ranges over zero to one in
particular you
you're interested in the supremum of
this modulus
of the unit interval and you've got this
additional constraint that the sum of
the
the absolute the some of the modulus
moduli
of the coefficients of this power series
b
um is bounded by m where m sum some
number
um more formally you've got p of t
um given by this complex power series
with
c one equal to one um and some of these
the
the magnitudes of these coefficients is
bounded by m whereby m is bounded
uh m is at least three over two uh the
exact value of three over two doesn't
really matter too much all that really
matters is that it's bounded above
one and we are we've been asking this
question um we asked this question
how large must the supreme of the
margins of the star series be
over the unit interval and our answer to
this question
is the following we show that this this
quantity is at least
on the order of one over log squared m
and the proof of this um this this lemma
it uses the hadamard three circles
theorem
i'm not going to be going over the proof
of this video and i also want to say
that this band is tied
we have a construction using chebyshev
polynomials which which matches this
bound
so returning to the the proof of the
telegram analog for symmetric convex
sets
we had this expression for
the difference in the inner product at
two different noise rates
um in terms of a2 times
pt where pt was this power series and we
we wanted to lower bound the supremum of
this power series
over the unit interval and because of
the previous complex analytic lemma
um that i just showed you uh
it follows that the supremum of p of t
and t ranges over zero to one is
on the order is at least on the order of
one over log squared 1 over a2
so so just to verify that this power
series b meets the conditions on the
previous slide
um it's its constant term is 0. it's a
linear coefficient is 1 and the sum of
the absolute values of the coefficients
of p of t
is bounded by uh 1 over a2
and a2 is non-negative this is not too
hard to see because of ryan's proof
so we've got a lower band on the supreme
of
this this difference of the inner
product um because of
supreme because of the lower bound of
the supreme of pfd
sd range of the unit interval and
because of ryan's proof
we know that this inner product is
increasing in row
in other words um the the difference in
the inner product
of euro k and l at noise rate one and at
noise
rate zero is at least on the order of
a two over log squared 1 over a2 in
other words it's equal to
some constant times um this function fee
that we showed up
that showed up earlier um and the input
to this function phi is a2
and just to be completely clear v of x
is just x over log squared one over x
and this this is this is a quantitative
version of ryan's inequality
but i promised you a quantitative
version which had this notion of
influences
so let's maybe look at this this
quantity a2 a bit more
uh closely so given two symmetric convex
sets a2 was defined to be the
product of the hermit coefficients of k
and l of degree two
um the
product of the corresponding unit
coefficients of canada
and let's look at how
um let's look at these hermit
coefficients of degree do
so just some notation um let e i denote
the standard
basis vector in in um
n dimensional space where the i entry is
one and all the other entries are zero
and if the if the degree of
um an n-tuple of natural numbers alpha
is two
then either it's either got two non-zero
entries which are both ones
or it's got a single non-zero entry
which is two and everything else is zero
and it's it's actually not super hard to
see that
if um you've got a symmetric convex set
k
then there's some suitable rotation of
this set um
rotation of the space such that all
these mixed
meat coefficients die out in other words
this is
k till the uh alphas are going to be
zero whenever
alpha is a degree to hermit coefficient
of the
form um e i plus e j or in other words
alpha has
two non-zero entries which are both ones
and now that you've you've performed
this rotation um
you can actually write a two as the
sum of the products of these degree two
hermet coefficients
where the coefficients of the form are
of the form two e i for some
um i ranging between zero and one
and in spite by the resemblance but with
telegram's inequality it's a
it turns out to be um
it's a natural thing to define these
hermite coefficients these degree two
hermet coefficients as the influences
um we're going to be negating them and
the reason for this will become clear on
the next slide
so given a symmetric convex set k we're
going to define the influence
in the eighth direction as this negated
hermit coefficient
um where
the hermite coefficient is the degree
two coefficient with one
um with it with one zero one non-zero
entry nearly a two
um at the eighth coordinate and a zero
everywhere else
and so this this quantity a2 is nothing
but the sum of the
products of the the corresponding
influences of k n l
and let me actually say why we um why
it's actually
not an insane thing to think about this
these influences um
these negated degree to hamit
coefficients as influences um in
in particular this it we show that
the influence um of a symmetric convex
set k
is now negative with equality if and
only if k is entirely independent of
um that the eighth coordinate
and so this is this is in some sense
this resembles what uh
the influences for boolean functions in
the n-dimensional hypercube uh behave
like
and many other interesting analogies
seem to hold and we've been exploring
this this notion
uh further so here's the quantitative
uh gaussian correlation inequality that
we prove
it says that asymmetrical sets um
the the correlation of any symmetric
convex sets can be
lower bounded by this function phi of
the sum of the products of the
influences
uh where this function for e of x is
defined to be x over
log squared 1 over x let me finally say
a little bit about how this strategy
generalizes to other domains
so let's look at what we really did we
had some probability space
rn and that with the gaussian
distribution
and we were interested in this this
correlation quantity
and we interpolated between
uh we interpolated between this
expectation
of f times g and expectation of f times
the expectation of g
and in in in the setting of symmetrical
convex sets with gas in space we
interpolated using this
instant erlenbach noise operator but
more general way of doing this is
to define an appropriate markov semi
group on this probability space
we then expressed it as a power series
using the hamid basis and more generally
we can
uh express it as a power series using
the eigen functions of
of of an appropriately defined markov
semi group
and finally we we use the monotonicity
of this interpolation
um and this is often available in the
form of off-the-shelf
results because as was in the case with
with
the gaussian correlation inequality um
many qualitative correlation
inequalities have been proved by
uh proving this the monotonicity of this
interpolation
and so this lets us obtain um telegram
analogues over a bunch of different over
a bunch of different domains
um and one thing which i want to
emphasize is that there doesn't seem to
be
a canonical choice of of markov semi
group to put on some of these domains
for example over the solid cube um 0 1
to the n
you could either put the ultra spherical
markov semi group which diagonalizes the
the legendary polynomials
or you could put the reflected heat semi
group
which diagonalizes the cosine basis
and for each choice of these this
microsemi group you get a
you get a seemingly different
quantitative correlation inequality
so to summarize we have this this
we have this approach to getting
quantitative correlation inequalities
from qualitative ones
and the two main ingredients going into
this approach are this is this
this idea to interpolate using noise
operators
which people have done before um and we
have this
complex analytic lemma which may be of
independent interest
um which bounds the supremium norm of
complex power series of bounded length
and we also have this new notion of
influence for symmetric convex sets of a
gaussian space
which is pretty exciting and lots of
interesting analogies with
some results from boolean function and
analysis seem to hold
if you made it this far thanks for
watching